[Music]
let's go to mary in casey missouri
what's up mary what's up
hey dr john how are you today i'm good i
love you
i'm wonderful i'm so
just honored to be speaking with you so
i reached out um
we have a son so i i re i'm divorced and
remarried we have a blended family and
our middle child who's my oldest is 18
and he's a freshman in college
we are in baby step 7 and so
we
you know he really wanted to go away to
school
he struggled his senior year of high
school
and so with grades and that kind of
thing you struggle academically
psychologically yes
academically
started to do some poor you know made
some poor choices with drinking and
vaping and that kind of thing
um my husband and i had a lot of talks
with him about you know this is a fresh
start we believe in you and he really
wanted to go away so he did so he's he's
down in the ark at university of
arkansas okay and uh really really
really struggled um
classes uh
just
like he's very social right so he's high
social didn't get into a fraternity made
a lot of friends
and the social life just took over
and
so here we are at the end of the
semester he's on his way home right now
and um has all f's
so
um he has a life coach and he's worked
with her for about a year now
and we've all believed in him and we
really really want to see him succeed
um
he has he really really wants to go back
but it's expensive right and i i i'm
just at a loss as to what to do i want
to his his dad told him he would not pay
for uh last semester so that's when my
husband and i did so now it's his dad's
turn to
pay
and
it's just really hard because he's
failed and yet right he's only 18 and i
believe in him and i i'm just so
confused as to as to what to do and i'm
concerned about him he's admitted that
he's drinking a lot
um i know that he vapes quite a bit he
says all of his friends are vaping
um so i'm concerned about his health i'm
concerned about his future
and just kind of lost so i reached out
to you because i think the world of you
well i appreciate that and i've i've had
this conversation i can't even tell you
probably a thousand times in my career
with
with people in your exact situation so
um
here's what i'll tell you
um the greatest gift you could give your
18 year old son right now
is to feel the weight of the
consequences of his actions
and that will be hard on you
it will feel like a betrayal to him
but he's 18 year old man
now
as much as he's a kid he's a child and
you're gonna hear me tell other people
that you're eight they're 18 year olds
or children and i will i'm telling you
yours is a is an adult
um
you're playing a long game with him now
you're playing a what does a 30 year old
son look like and we're gonna reverse
engineer that
and so right now it feels like the whole
world
it feels like everything's crashing down
you feel like a failure because your kid
failed and what did we do and could it
be this and is it the divorce all those
things
you can get existential about it and
that's fine and all good the reality is
he went to college he decided to drink
and party and hang out and he flunked
out
he's going to be on academic probation
if it's my son my son's coming home and
he's going to get a job and he's going
to go to community college and prove to
me that he wants to be in school
and
the way the language i use in my house
is all about choice
so if one of my um
my son i hate when parents weaponize uh
interactions with kids meaning
oh you didn't get your thing done well
you're not coming fishing with me
i don't like that but here's what i do
the same the consequence is the same but
the semantics means everything
i will sit down with my son and say i
did this recently
if x and y and z does not happen
that is you choosing to not come spend
time with me at this on this trip
and i will choose to be heartbroken
because this trip is no fun without you
i don't like hunting or fishing alone
without my son
and if you choose to
go to bed early or hang out and not get
your stuff done
i will be sad that that was your choice
and in the same
and so i'm i'm i'm not weaponizing my
relationship i'm letting him know that
the weight of this interaction is on his
shoulders he's got some choices to make
and i would sit down with your son and
have that same conversation
i want you to go to college i want you
to go to university arkansas where
you're where it's a great school and
it's great this and career and blah blah
great
so far you have chosen to drink and to
party and to fail
that's the choice you made and i i'm
choosing to be heartbroken about that
because i know you're smarter than that
and i know you're more capable of that
but these are choices you made if you
choose to get all a's at community
college then i will choose to reinvest
in your education but at this point the
choices you've made suggest that you
don't even want to be in college
see how that i want him to feel the
weight of the decisions and the choices
he made of course he wants to go back of
course all of his friends are there of
course all the girl of his dreams is
there of course all of the
but the choices you made i want a
million dollars too but if i spend all
my money every day then i'm choosing to
not have a million dollars
right
so the greatest gift you could give him
is to let him know that there are
consequences to his choices
and to what and to love him the whole
way through by the way love them the
whole way through some parents have to
gear themselves up for this conversation
it ends up being a so yeah so you gotta
i wouldn't do that let them know that
you're heartbroken too
if so
thank you this is really good couple
different scenarios he's meeting with
his dad tomorrow and he's asking dad i
want to go back please believe in me
he's written him a letter et cetera et
cetera they don't have a very good
relationship
if dad chooses to fund
the next semester which is completely
out of my control yep
then what
then here's what's going to happen
he's going to go back and he's going to
flunk out and they're not going to let
him go to college there ever again
and so the number of times i counseled
students and their parents away from the
college where i was getting money for
their enrollment
so that they didn't put themselves in a
position where they could never go again
and by the way if you flunk out you've
got to report that on every application
to another college you ever try to make
and so whatever life coach y'all have by
the way sounds like they're terrible
like i i just i'm paying for a year of a
life coach and my kid drinks his way
through freshman year i'm not going to
pay that life coach ever again
right yeah like i don't know the life
life coach r us program on the internet
i don't know
um
but i
like i would never let my kid go back
without a game plan without really
strict accountability who's gonna walk
alongside you who's gonna and by the way
i'm a grown-up i don't have time to
babysit my 18 year olds like i want to
see all your assignments and dude you're
in college right that's the thing
will do we have weekly you know my
wonderful husband has said he can report
to me every friday at five or whatever
what his grades are i'm like this just
doesn't i don't know i it doesn't feel
like he's 18. you know and at the
university of arkansas i guarantee you
they've got a counseling center and a
tutoring center and a academic support
center and
faculty tutors and gas that help the
faculty tutors the chances to be you
have to decide i don't want to be
successful
at the university of arkansas for you to
flunk out it has to be a choice you make
and if you've got uh
learning disabilities or learning
exceptionalities they've got ada office
and the 504 8504 stuff they've got all
kinds of
organizations and groups and
the resources are endless
and your son made a choice to flunk out
of college
or flunk the semester
and so the the most loving thing i think
anybody does is doesn't set him up self
up in a position to you don't buy your
16 year old a ferrari
because they don't need that i i'm
protecting you from the from your bad
decision
i want you if you're gonna hit the gas i
want you to hit a honda accord gas not
ferrari gas right i want you to make an
80 mile an hour wreck not a 280 mile an
hour wreck
well right and i mean he had his he had
his car we had to take his car away he
was driving too fast we warned him and
warned him we got rid of his car
and similarly reckless
yes yes yes and so i don't want him to
be put in a situation where
he's gonna have his 18 year old plans i
really really want this and hey i
believe he really wants it i believe he
got embarrassed i believe he's ashamed i
believe it was a wake-up call i get it
i think there's an old bobby knight
little basketball coach who said
everybody
wants to be a champion everybody on the
court wants to win that game
but the game's not won on that court the
game is won the year before in the
weight room and in the practice room and
in the film room
right and so your son really wants this
but he doesn't have a plan he doesn't
have the acumen he doesn't have a
success strategy he doesn't have any
he's had two years now or a year and a
half of
of
substandard academic success he needs to
get a couple of wins under his belt get
that at a local community college either
for free if if arkansas has that program
i don't know what state you're in oh
yeah you're in kansas missouri uh if
they've got the uh if they've got a free
community college program or it's gonna
be like 50 bucks an hour or whatever go
do that
right
but set him up in a position to
get some little wins so that he can
choose to make bigger win decisions
and this is one of those i don't know
what your relationship is with your
ex-husband but i'd call him and say i'm
i know i can't have i don't have any say
into what next semester looks like i
believe the best thing for our son is
that he feel the weight of his
consequences and that he spends a
semester at a community college let him
show us this is what he wants i i know
that it could be pie in the sky
depending on what kind of partnership
you have with your ex
but i would probably make that phone
call
let him know you love him
your son and let him know he's got to
feel the weight of the consequences of
his choices
thank you so much for the call mary
great great question great question